when a physicist says the word
information what does it mean does it
have anything to do with digital
information let's dive real deep into
this rabbit hole
hey crazies I've been meaning to do a
video what information for a while now
it's tricky though because the word
information means different things to
different people this is a much deeper
question than it sounds it demands a
longer video over on my speed of light
video I said light was the fastest thing
and some of you had some complaints
about it
IBG pointed out that there are distant
parts of the universe moving away from
us faster than the speed of light I was
also having a conversation with schemey
swab in the comments and it went a
little something like this if all motion
is relative can't I say that all the
stars and galaxies are moving around me
faster than the speed of light no
they're moving so slow you can barely
tell they're moving at all yeah but
they're really far away so isn't that
still a lot of motion for them well the
conversation made me realize this needed
some serious clarification first of all
he's correct if we look out at some
distant star in space now screw that
let's be more specific there's a star on
the shoulder of Orion called Betelgeuse
that's pretty bright technically it's
pronounced metal jaws that but no one
ever says it right if we watch
Betelgeuse in the sky for say six hours
it'll sweep out a 90 degree angle which
doesn't seem very far in the sky but if
we take into consideration that
Betelgeuse is hundreds of light years
away then the distance it appears to
travel is for lack of a better word
astronomical that distance divided by
the six hours is most definitely larger
than the speed of light you could say
something like but Betelgeuse didn't
really move in that six hours the earth
just rotated and you'd be right but so
is the person that said Betelgeuse moved
remember relativity says all
perspectives are in equal footing
neither one of these perspectives is
wrong Betelgeuse is either not moving or
moving faster than light and that's fine
wait wait how is it fine that Betelgeuse
is traveling faster than light because
information still isn't traveling faster
than light when we do physics on paper
we can draw the picture from several
points of view it can give us the
impression that we're omnipresent or
something but we have to remember that
we are somehow always part of that
picture we have to take those
measurements we're making predictions
about the only reason we even know
anything about Betelgeuse is because it
emits light
that takes hundreds of years to get to
earth the fact that it looks like it's
moving faster than light to us doesn't
matter because it's always doing this
hundreds of light years away
the only interactions we have with
Betelgeuse are those travelling photons
which go at exactly the speed of light
from everyone's point of view Oh
photons and information are the same
thing why didn't you just say that
stop jumping to conclusions all right so
information if we're going to explain
something away with it we better know
what it means let's start back before
this word was even being used back when
the speed of light was a hot debate
always the rebel Galileo was pretty sure
the speed of light was finite that it
took time to get from one place to
another he even suggested measuring it
using a couple mountains and a lantern
but light is just too fast for an
experiment that simple Newton was firmly
in the infinite speed camp he was
convinced that light travelled from one
place to another in no time at all and
even applied the idea to his universal
law of gravity he said that if the Sun
just disappeared the earth would
instantly respond to its strange and
sudden absence luckily by the end of
that century people like Romer and
Hawkins had taken measurements proving
Newton wrong the speed of light is
finite so by the early 1700s we knew
light took time to get places and we
were ready to start talking about
information but we didn't the fact that
light was finite was more of a nuisance
than anything else it was just something
you had to adjust for in your data when
you looked into space it wasn't really a
part of scientific conversation until we
started to realize how big the universe
really was and where it came from and
that took a while beautiful images like
this take hours or sometimes days of
exposure which means we needed cameras
to be invented first the oldest known
photograph has been dated to 1826 and it
was good timing too because that's when
physics really started to change several
measurements of the speed of light
discovery that light was an
electromagnetic wave and the speed of
light was constant special relativity
space-time diagrams general relativity
then in 1924 Edwin Hubble measured the
distance to Andromeda and found it was
millions of light years away from Earth
Way past anything anyone could have
imagined
in 1927 George Lemaitre predicted the
universe was expanding much to Einsteins
dismay and then Hubbell returned in 1929
with more measurements showing the
universe was in fact expanding why is
this important
we're getting there be patient let's
review we know the speed of light is
finite and it's the same for all
observers we also know the universe is
billions of light years across and
billions of years old if light takes
time to get places then we're not
looking at the universe in real time the
farther away something is the further
back in time we're looking so now it's
important to start talking about
information say we want to affect the
Centauri system for light-years away the
fastest thing we can send there is light
which has a finite speed we have to wait
for years for that light to get there
the same is true if the Centauri system
wants to affect us if we both send a
signal at the same time those signals
would pass through each other here so
that's the earliest we could interact
with each other diagonal light paths
form something we call a light cone we
can only interact with the Centauri
system where our light cones overlap
this applies to everything whether there
are people or not the upper limit on the
speed of interactions is the speed of
light including gravity any speed you
observe to be faster than light is okay
as long as that speed doesn't causally
connect to events in space-time that
super fast star from earlier is okay
because from that point of view the rest
of the universe is moving with it it's
not getting any closer to anything else
the speed of light isn't the speed of
light it's the speed of causality it's
the speed of information without this
upper limit the universe would have
effects before causes dogs and cats
living together mass hysteria fine it's
the speed of information but what is
information oh right well it can't be
matter or energy because those sometimes
break the limit the modern form of the
term information wasn't really used
until we started communicating with
technology in 1948 a huge paper was
published on how we transmit data let's
say you want to send this message
whether you send it by cable radio wave
or some other method it has to be
converted into some kind of signal a
transmitter consent that signal is sent
to a receiver where it's converted back
into a message the more data the signal
contains the harder it is the same
the longer it takes to send and the more
likely some of it will be lost along the
way so you want that message to be
converted into as little data as
possible it's why these different copies
of the same picture have vastly
different file sizes the same amount of
information is contained using different
amounts of data that same 1948 paper
mentions a quantity that they call
information entropy which tells you the
smallest amount of data required to
contain a certain amount of information
for example English is between point six
and one point three data bits per
English character they decided to call
it entropy because the equation is
incredibly similar to physical entropy
back to the time line Rudolf Clausius
first used the word entropy in 1865 but
it didn't look much like what we would
eventually call information entropy
until Boltzmann and Gibbs got their
hands on it in 1877 see the resemblance
they didn't really understand what it
meant though because at the time no one
was sure what matter was even made of
the electron wasn't discovered until
1897 and we wouldn't see an atomic model
that looked anything like the modern
atom until 1911 it was around then we
started to realize what was going on
that mixed-up 'no siz about how the
energy inside an object's atoms is
organized the more ways that energy
could be organized the less information
you actually have about it it keeps
shifting between all the possibilities
over time the universe tends to have
more and more ways to organize the
energy so the entropy of the universe is
always going up that's the second law of
thermodynamics but we have to be careful
about comparing data information to
physical information data is something
humans made up the physical world is not
inside of something like your body you
have all sorts of atoms exchanging
energy with each other and the
surroundings let's consider something a
little simpler the Sun is emitting
something we call solar wind it's
basically just a bunch of particles like
protons and electrons let's focus our
attention on a single proton if it bumps
into another proton energy is exchanged
and their entropy goes up when it's not
bumping into anything it's entropy stays
steady but if it's not interacting with
anything it's a quantum object which
means there are things you can't know
about it the uncertainty principle says
quantum particles are only particular
about a few properties at a time all
others are pretty indefinite
so when the proton interacts with
something its properties will change
some of the definite ones might change
value some of them might become
indefinite and some of the indefinite
ones might become definite we can't know
for sure ahead of time
stupid quantum physics the physical
information of the proton is some
composite measure of where it is what
it's doing how much mass charge and
energy it has you know its properties no
matter what happens less is knowable
about the universe as a whole
information is always lost and the
change in entropy just measures how much
we lost I'm stretching this a little
here but what if we're all just made of
information and over time that
information fades away as it interacts
with itself let me know what you think
in the comments and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy